the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
video in this video we will be looking
at the second episode from house of the
dragons first season i'm sorry everyone
but before we get started there is
something i must do
there we go that's much better well my
friends here we are once again and i
must say i really enjoyed the new
episode now before we go any further i
want to discuss the sponsor of this
video atlas vpn as i'm sure most of you
already know all of us are at risk of
having our identity stolen on a daily
basis as more and more of our
information and data goes onto the
internet what some of you might not know
is that one of the best ways from
stopping this from happening is by the
use of a vpn service this is something
that i've actually been using every day
for the last six months well this month
i've joined forces with atlas vpn to
bring you the most affordable deal on
online protection for as little as one
dollar and 83 cents each month not to
mention they also have a 30-day
money-back guarantee now other than
guarding your online identity atlas vpn
also blocks malware and malicious links
another thing it does is keep your
google searches private and even gives
you access to online shopping deals and
will notify you whenever someone is
trying to steal your identity one of my
favorite things about atlas vpn is it
also gives you access to other region's
content on the different streaming
services like netflix
for example if something is only
available in the uk all you have to do
is switch your ip address to gain access
to it in the us right now atlas vpn is
running a massive discount to where you
can actually get a three-year
subscription for only one dollar and 83
cents a month and like i said that has a
30-day money-back guarantee as well you
can jump on that deal right now before
the time runs out by going to the link
in my description i would recommend
grabbing that deal now once again i
would like to thank atlas vpn for
sponsoring the video now let's get back
into the new episode
now there was an immediate difference
with this episode than the first one
right out of the gate we finally got our
intro scene before the actual episode
began
although this one is somewhat different
it does sort of look feel and sound the
same as the original from game of
thrones
as you all know the game of thrones
theme is so legendary i don't mind
hearing it again in house of the dragon
now like the first episode this one
started out a bit slow as well as much
as i would like to get right into the
action i do understand we still need
some time to set everything up and
establish who everyone is and what
direction they will be heading in for
the foreseeable future
now this second episode actually takes
place about 6 months after the first
episode ended again i was worried this
might not work that well but i must say
it did not bother me at all there's a
lot of events this first season must
establish before the dance of the
dragons begins one thing i really liked
about the episode is how it fleshed out
some of the other characters like
lorcorlus valerion masaria and a few
others we're finally seeing just who
they are and where they stand on certain
issues in this episode we see how
viserys targaryen is dealing with the
aftermath of losing his wife and son now
that six months have gone by many of his
advisors are expecting him to get
married again something viserys hadn't
really considered at least not yet now i
gotta be honest viserys and allison
actually seem great together although
their age difference is bothersome when
you look at who they are and how they
act they really do seem like they're
made for one another and maybe under
different circumstances their
relationship might really blossom but as
we all know this is game of thrones in a
wedding without at least three deaths is
considered a doll affair i think it's
funny how viserys is always messing
around with his legos whenever alison
visits him as we saw in this episode
viserys's marriage announcement did not
go over well with everyone now serato he
actually looked like he had a heart on
when viserys made the announcement but
rhaenyra and lord corliss velaryon were
understandably very upset once again
lord corliss velaryon gets slapped right
in the face
house velaryon getting shoved aside is
becoming its own theme now i will say i
was glad this did happen though because
i did not want to see viserys walking
hand in hand with laina velaryon again
the thought of him getting married to
this little girl is disturbing although
allison isn't a much better option
either at least allison's actress looks
of age whereas laina obviously looks
like a very small child i can't even
begin to imagine what must be going
through rhaenyra's mind the matter of
succession is one thing but your dad
getting married to your best friend is
something entirely different she has to
feel betrayed not only by her friend but
her father as well this wasn't the only
time viserys made her feel like [ __ ]
either one thing i really loved about
rhaenyra in this episode was how she
volunteered to go fight in the
stepstones on dragon back viserys was
obviously not a fan of the idea he must
not have seen game of thrones season 8
because if he did he would have seen
just how surgical daenerys was on her
dragon i think rhaenyra would have been
just fine as long as she had cyrax
underneath of her another one of my
favorite moments from this episode was
the scene on dragonstone now this was
incredible the beginning of this scene
felt like something right out of a scary
movie dragonstone had this dark and
ominous feeling about it which made the
scene even better it set the stage for
the amazing confrontation with daemon in
serato once again showing the hatred
these men have for one another and i do
think rhaenyra was right if she hadn't
shown up and made damon stop serato's
blood most likely would have been shed
right there as we all know daemon
already doesn't like him but then he had
to nerf to insult him his fiancee and
their child right in front of everyone
serato went over the line and he knew it
all this scene does is make me want to
see more moments like this involving
daemon and serato hightower they're so
much fun to watch this also made the
final scene even better after getting
dissed by the king one too many times
daemon targaryen and lord cordless
valerion join forces to finally stop the
crab feeder in the stepstones now we
know it won't be long before we start to
see fire rain down on their enemies in
the south of the narrow sea
we will most likely see them head for
the stepstones in the very next episode
where they will face off against the
crab feeder and his men and it won't
only be daemon his dragon karaxis and
the valerion fleet we will also see them
enlist the help of different adventurers
as well as the sellswords the second
sons they will finally be able to get
out some of their frustrations brought
on by the decisions of their king this
will be the start of a great
relationship that will ultimately end
with several marriage alliances not only
demons but rhaenyras as well this
relationship will further influence
house velaryon to stand at rhaenyra and
daemon's side once the dance of the
dragons begins
now since i'm mentioning the dragons i
also want to say something about vegar
like we saw in the episode we hear that
he's missing in action the largest and
oldest living dragon in westeros is
nowhere to be found my guess is she will
show up right when they need her i hope
we start to see more dragons in these
next few episodes we still need to see
melee sunfire vegar and so many more
like i said earlier i thought this was a
great episode once things started moving
along now that viserys and allison are
getting married this basically sets up
the stage for the remainder of this
series the main conflict has now been
set in motion and it won't be long
before viserys and allison start having
sons which will ultimately challenge
rhaenyra's succession something that
rhaenys did warn her of in this episode
like rainey said those men who once wore
filthy to her will no longer stand at
her side once a male heir is born
rhaenyra is already getting the sense
that she might be set aside for another
but what makes it even worse is the fact
that her best friend will be the one who
makes sure that it happens
alison's son aegon and rhaenyra's fight
over the iron throne will last for
seasons leading to the death of not only
many targaryens but most of their
dragons as well
it will be interesting to see how all of
this unfolds now that we're already
seeing the line get drawn in the sand i
thought the episode did a great job at
showing how these sides will start to
get formed daemon and lorcorlus are
forming a bond of their own while
rhaenyra and alicense begins to crack at
its foundation although serato acts like
he's looking out for viserys's best
interest he's really only looking out
for his own as he ensures his family
holds onto their seat at the big table
i'm looking forward to seeing how all of
these relationships either evolve or
dissolve into nothing like i've said
before the downfall of house targaryen
has begun
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching my initial
reaction to the new episode make sure
you subscribe so you're the first to
know whenever i release a new video i
will have several new videos every week
during the whole season
let me know what you thought about this
new episode down below
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you